we've looked at Chomsky and we've looked
at finite state automata and you've give
me a sneak preview about what might be
next and my first thought was what do
all these notation marks mean and where
do they come from Chomsky instinctively
went for a notation that appeals to
mathematical solutions or theoretical
computer scientists nowadays very tight
very compact what he would basically say
about a programming and creature
identifier which we're trying to define
is that everything in Chomsky's world is
a sentence we've covered this already in
the carpark a legal sentence in this
language is five five five five five so
everything is an S in Chomsky notations
what he would say about the identifier
x' problem in sensible languages we've
got to start off with a letter I'll call
that l and then the tail piece of the
identifier well it could be nothing at
all because a single letter is an
identifier pretty well every language
but the tail piece could be more letters
more digits in any combination fine now
round about the time late fifties
turning into 1960 there was a whole
bunch of them defining the language
Algol which was the first language to be
designed by a committee and ran into all
the usual committee problems but when
you think back to that era Fortran was
their cores there they never until later
on had a formal definition the alcohol
people said we are going to use
something like Chomsky notation to
define what's a legal program John
Backus and peter naur who were on the
kögel 60 defining committee Backus was
famous as one of the big inventors of
Fortran peter naur very famous european
computer scientist they said we need
something that is more self explanatory
and they invented a notation that looks
like this pointy brackets yes this early
on and we are going to say an identifier
not a sentence it's an identifier we're
trying to define and rather than using
Chomsky's arrow which they felt might
occur in the middle of
program and cause confusion they wanted
is defined as operation here which
wouldn't ever occur inside a program
they wanted to be clear it's part of the
definition and they said easy we're not
gonna call it L we're gonna say letter
and you see the advantage straightaway
that you can then say ah it's a letter
followed by a tail piece which we'll
call tail by putting things in the
pointy brackets we're saying we don't
literally mean you must look for the
characters le tter on your import no we
mean anything that can be a legal letter
so further down here there be another
definition saying the letter is an A or
B or C all the way up to Z and all that
tail piece is far more complicated
because it's any mix of further letters
or further the digits but there could be
a definition for digits but the point is
they're readable things here
they're readable notions as they're
sometimes called and they're pretty well
self-explanatory far more appealing to
you setting out a definition of a
programming language than your for ever
having to remember o letter capital D is
that a digit or is it two and
denominator you know of course the
theoretician say oh it's far too verbose
but yes I expect I do understand you've
got to make it clear to people who've
got no break exactly what's going on so
this was very popular for defining
languages so this is a bit like having
how to guide is it like saying okay this
is not programming this is how the
programming works exactly it's a
blueprint for legal programs all of them
they've got to fit into this template
basically that's what the formal
definition did and the interesting thing
as many of you are yelling at me now is
this is XML then there it is the
forerunner of XML XML as some of you
know started off with a thing called
sgml which was its earlier form but it
was refined into being XML and right
back from the earliest GML days
somebody saw backus-naur form the
notation and said that is going to be
fantastically useful for what we want to
do
the characteristic of this stuff is that
you never see it in the actual language
itself we can see advantages in actually
making these appear in documents we all
know there's no way we all accidentally
see a listing of our webpage that went
wrong and you see things like pointy
bracket be pointed bracket so this is
XML be clear you see things like Br and
actually if anyone right clicks on the
Yuchi webpage and says view source the
embassy all they see this all but what
the XML people realized was that so long
as you introduce the end of slash just
elaborate the notation of it you really
could use it in an actual document so
that paragraph starts here the program
ends here the breakline here it starts
it finishes it's just a marker and most
browsers are tolerant if you miss the
slash out but you know but theoretically
that should be there so they gave us a
new lease of life really by saying well
we're not just gonna keep it in the
abstract we're just gonna use it within
documents to clearly delineate where
things start and where things finish we
absolutely to the worst-case and we say
well what is the most complex frame we
could reasonably receive it's this okay
can we decode that in less than a frames
worth of time yes we can you know and we
prove it